today I am going to show you how to make
a Simon game using mainly JavaScript but
also HTML and CSS Simon is a game it's
it's based on a real game a physical
game in real life and we're going to
recreate it with JavaScript and there is
a a four different lights or colors and
they will light up in a certain order so
the player has to remember the order
each round an additional light is added
and the player has to remember all the
the order so far in the game until you
get to 20 rounds and then you win the
game so let's see what the final product
is going to look like so here's how the
Simon game works there are the this
power button the strict button the start
button so this is supposed to simulate a
physical Simon toy game and the physical
Simon toy game has a power switch so
that's what this this checkbox turns the
game on you can see when I click the
power button you can see right in this
count square this red line appears to
indicate that the game is on and then
the strict mode means that if you get
one wrong answer you lose the whole game
so if strict mode is on you get one
wrong answer and the whole game is lost
with strict mode off if you get a wrong
answer you can start from where you left
off so let me show you an example how it
works this is a memory matching game so
you have to remember the order of the
colors let's do this if I press Start so
I have to remember the order of these
oh I got it wrong so since I got it
wrong it starts from where I left off so
let's do this again you will notice that
for every round that count goes up by
one and if I get something wrong that
count flashes no so it starts from where
I left off because I'm not in strict
mode but if I turn on strict mode and I
get it wrong you can see this count is
gonna go down to one because I got it
wrong and I had to start the game all
over again so let's go into the code
because this is what we're going to be
building okay I have sublime text open
on the left and then I just have my
browser with the Simon game open on the
right and in this tutorial I'm mainly
going to focus on the JavaScript so I
already have the HTML and the CSS
written you can see the HTML file here
the CSS file here the JavaScript file is
empty so I'm going to review the HTML
the CSS and show you how those work and
then I'm actually going to write all the
JavaScript and explain that as I go
first let's see how the project is
structured so my root folder just Simon
game and then I have my index the HTML
file that's the file you see here and
then I have a JavaScript folder and a
CSS folder now inside these folders
they're just one file so really we could
have probably put all of this into the
root folder but it's good to get into
just the mindset of the best practices
and generally you'll have all of your
JavaScript and in one folder and all of
your CSS in another folder so right now
we're not going to need to see this file
structure again so I'll just close that
ok and let me just readjust this a
little bit and I'm going to start going
through this HTML here so you can see
from here to here is the heading now
this is stuff that's not going to really
appear on
Paige but it's stuff important for the
page the first thing I want to point out
is this font here I'm bringing in a
Google font now Google makes all these
fonts that you can use on websites there
they're free to use and you can they
have a lot of unique fonts that you can
use so that's the word Simon here uses
the Google font
it's called original surfer so if you
just look up google fonts it gives you
instructions on how to include them in
your in your web page and also there's
Google font effects so you can see right
here it says effect equals emboss and
that's why you can kind of see a border
around around this it's embossed and
google fonts have all sorts of effects
you can use so I would highly recommend
looking up google fonts and the effects
if you're not already familiar with them
and then here is where we link to our
CSS file that's the one right here and
then something else we'll look at is how
we are basically importing these audio
files to use so there's four different
audio files we have the audio tag and
there's the opening and closing tag in
HTML most tags have opening and closing
tags and we have these sets of different
IDs which we will reference later in our
JavaScript and the source is just this
file right here if you're following
along you can use these same files or
you can use your own files so we have
the four different audio files for the
sounds that are gonna play when each of
the buttons are pressed before I go over
the rest of the HTML so this HTML here
is what actually makes up the actual
page that you can see here but let's go
over to the CSS I'm not going to go
through everything on here
I will link
to both the HTML and the CSS in the
description of the video so you're not
gonna have to type all this out if
you're following along you can just
download the HTML file and the CSS file
in fact all these files will be on the
github repository that's linked to in
the description so you can see for the
body you can you can really use anything
for the background but I just use this
repeating pattern here that's why we
have this texture and we could have also
used a solid color and then this is just
standard CSS you can see that I'm using
the Google font for some of these things
and so for CSS just a quick refresher if
you have a dot that's going to apply to
a class and then if you have a hash mark
like this it's going to apply to an ID
so now I'll actually explain that a
little more once we get back to our HTML
here so in the body of our HTML we have
this outer circle and this outer circle
you can see this is the opening div tag
and this is the closing end tag so
everything is within the outer circle
that's this dark black circle all around
here and then here we have the top left
top right bottom left bottom right and
those are just these colors here and the
IDS are important for two reasons the
point of IDs is that they're there's
only one of them so where as classes you
can have multiple things with the same
class IDs you can only have one element
with the same ID so we use the IDS in
our CSS that's one of the ways we use
them for instance with this top left
here if I go in here if I scroll down I
will be able to see top left and this is
the CSS to create this
Green section here you can even see
background is dark green here the other
purpose of the IDs is that we can
reference them in JavaScript and a lot
of these we are gonna reference in
JavaScript because we are going to add
click handlers and we are going to use
JavaScript to show what's going to
happen when you click the different
elements on the page so we also have
this inner circle
that's this grey circle here and it has
a bunch of stuff inside the inner circle
you can see nestled within the circle so
we have the title and you can see that
there's a special class font infect
emboss and that's how we get the effect
on this from the google font and then we
have these switches the switches are
these check marks here now we could
change these check parts to be toggle
switches or buttons or something that
would look more similar to the physical
Simon game toy but for now I just have
them as checkboxes like well we have the
power button the strict button and then
we also have the start button so if you
want to improve upon this project one
idea would be to style these a little a
little more to look like actual buttons
or toggles or switches you could do that
using CSS or maybe even use some
JavaScript for that so we have these
three buttons here and then we just have
the labels power and strict now turn
that's this box here that's going to
tell what turn we're on when we're
playing the game and that's pretty much
everything here the last thing I want to
show you in the HTML is this script tag
that links to our JavaScript file and
you'll see it's at the very end now the
the CSS is up here at the top we link to
the CSS file but we link to the
javascript file at the end some people
do link to Joshua files at the beginning
just like the CSS file but it's really
best practice to link to the JavaScript
at the end and that is because we want
to make sure all of the HTML is loaded
before we load the JavaScript because
the JavaScript is going to reference
some of the items in the HTML and so if
the JavaScript loaded too quickly before
the HTML was loaded it could create some
problems ok it's time to get to the good
stuff the JavaScript so hopefully you're
following along and actually typing this
all out yourself that's how you're
really gonna learn I mean you can just
watch and just try to learn just from
observing but if you actually type this
out yourself and follow along its gonna
help you understand the concepts a lot
more and you can try out different
things so like I said you can just
download the CSS and the HTML from from
the links in the description but the
JavaScript will be nice if you typed it
out with me so first we are going to
just type out some of the variables
we're gonna use so I'm gonna declare our
first variable with a let let order
equal and then I'm going to put an empty
array here these two brackets that's how
we're going to set this variable named
order to this array now JavaScript
you're usually going to end all your
lines with a semicolon let is a way to
initialize a variable there's there's
three different ways to initialize a
variable we have let we have var and
then there's Const and var I'm just
gonna do a brief overview of what the
different things are var will apply to
the entire scope of your entire program
let will be a little more of a limited
scope and only apply to where it was
defined and const stands for constant
and constants cannot be changed
so once you set a variable Wisconsin you
can't set it to something else later
so most people say you should only use
left and Const and you should never use
var so we're just going to use let here
so order this is a variable that's going
to keep track of the order of the lights
on how they're going to flash we're also
going to have let player order now this
is going to be the order that the player
is pressing the lights in and let flash
this is going to be a basically an
integer now with JavaScript you don't
set the types of the variables but
generally you do keep them at one type
for the most part and this is just gonna
be a number the number of flashes that
have appeared in the game we're also
going to have let turn to keep track of
what turn we're on let good and this is
going to be a boolean true or false
whether the player is doing well or not
if the player has hit all the right
colors or if the players not hit all the
right colors and let comp turn also is
going to be a boolean a true or false
it's going to keep track of whether it's
the computer's turn or the players turn
we're also going to have let interval ID
I'm going to explain that one a little
later then let strict is going to keep
track of if the strict button has been
the check mark has been checked it's
gonna start at false because it's gonna
start unchecked let noise equals true if
we're playing noise this will make more
sense later in the program let on equals
false and that's if the program has been
turned on the power button here and it's
going to start turned off and then let
when this is just going to say if the
player has won the game or not so now
we're going to use some constants we
have to have a way to get some of our
HTML elements to reference them in
JavaScript so that's what we're gonna do
here we're gonna try to we're going to
reference some of our HTML elements in
JavaScript I'm going to show you how to
do that we're gonna have the turn
counter now the turn counter is this
right here and we want to reference that
in JavaScript so I'm going to use this
document that query selector and then
I'm gonna pass in whoops I'm going to
pass in a CSS selector so I'm gonna just
type in turn here so when I do document
query selector I can pass in any CSS
selector and this hashtag term means it
an element with the ID of turn so if I
go into my HTML you'll see it right here
we have an ID of turn so now we've
actually taken that HTML element and put
it into this variable turn counter and
now we can use our JavaScript to
manipulate that we're gonna do that a
few more times Const top left equals
document that query selector and then
this time it will just be top left and
then we'll just kind of speed this up a
little bit okay you can see now I have a
variable for all the elements we're
gonna reference the top left top right
bottom left bottom right the strict
button the on button and the start
button these are all the elements that
you can interact with
besides the turn counter you can't
interact with the turn counter but all
these other elements we can interact
with and we are going to use JavaScript
for the interaction so we just used
the CSS selectors for each of those
elements like top left you can see here
idea of top left and then we got all
these elements into variables and since
they're always going to stay the same we
were able to use Const
so now that we have the variables set up
we can start writing the code that's
going to allow us to interact with the
game and play the game so how I'm going
to organize this is I'm going to write
the program in the order that you would
play the game so first of all you're
going to interact with these buttons
here lay like the power button the
strict button and the start button so
I'm just going to start we'll just start
with the strict button for now so I'm
going to reference the strict button now
this is the variable we just made up
here and I'm going to add event listener
and so if we add an event listener it's
going to be listening for some event on
that element and the event is going to
be change and so I'm going to pass in a
function now this is going to be an
arrow function here there's a couple
ways to make functions in JavaScript and
this is a common way for event listeners
where this is what we're going to be
passing into the function and you put
the arrow equal and then the the more
than sign and we have these curly braces
and this is what's going to happen when
that that check mark box is changed so
I'm gonna put if strict well before I
actually do this I want to actually show
you it working so let's just do a
console
that log and I'm going to say checked so
a console that log if we open up the
JavaScript console we can see something
happen with this so I'm going to save
this I'm going to refresh here now I'm
going to open up the JavaScript console
on the side here
now this if I click the strict button we
should see something appear here okay
you can see it now says checked because
this changed now this would actually
work you can see every time I click here
it increases the number because it's
saying that it has put that word that
many times this could really be also add
eventlistener click this could be click
or changed and it would do the same
thing because we're just trying to keep
track of when we clicked it or changed
it because we are going to in the code
the logic of the code it's going to
check whether that checkbox is checked
or not so let me show you that now first
of all I'll close the JavaScript console
and we'll just move this back over so we
can see the code a little better so what
I'm gonna do here is say if strict
button dot checked equals equals true so
that that's a way that we can see if
this is check now dot checked is only
gonna be something we can use if we're
dealing with the check box but since
strict button is a checkbox we can see
if it's checked as true or if it's not
checked it'll be false then we can do
something so if it's check if it's true
we're gonna set strict to equal true
else we are going to set strict to equal
false so this is just a standard if-else
statement so if it's checked this trick
should be true else strict should be
false
so we've now just finished that whole
button and we can go on to the next
button which is going to be the on
button so again I'm going to do an add
eventlistener
and again it's going to be a click event
and so I'll pass in the event you'll see
notice that above we pass in the event
to this function and we never use that
event here that's okay it's still that's
still when you're cream an event
listener you always pass in the event
even when you're not going to use that
event in the function so this time again
we're going to check if the on button
that checked equals equals true and so
if the on button is checked we'll do a
few now we're going to do two things we
are going to set on to equal true just
like we said strict equal true and we're
these variables come from up here on and
strict but we're gonna do one more thing
if you remember in the example I showed
you at the beginning when you turn the
power on we want to line to appear right
here to show that it's on so to do that
I'm going to do a turn counter dot inner
HTML now inner HTML well let me just
finish writing this line so this is
going to equal and just this - inner
HTML is something that you can use on
any HTML element to set the HTML to
something different so now the HTML
within this turn counter is going to be
this line
so if we looked in here right now here's
the turn counter and within the turn
counter is nothing between these two
brackets here there's nothing there but
when we do this turn counter to enter
HTML it's going to put a dash right in
the turn counter so we'll do then else
here we're gonna do on equals false and
then turn counter dot innerhtml equals
and we're going to set it back to
nothing so let's just see if this works
and I'll save that refresh and if I turn
the power on you'll now see this line up
here when I click check in uncheck it so
this is starting to have at least some
functionality we're gonna do a few more
things in the else here only make sure
it's it's higher so it's easier to see
so we're gonna do a few more things when
you turn this off so we're going to
clear the color so this is a function
this is how you call a function in
JavaScript I still need to define this
function but let's say you're playing
the game and one of the colors lit up
when you turn the power off all the
colors should all the lights should go
off or these the colors they're a
lighter color should go back to the
darker color and then the other thing
we're gonna do is to clear an interval
now I'm going to be talking more about
what this is more later when I define
the interval but I'll just put it here
now and we're gonna come back to that
you can see we we passed in this
interval I D so just keep this in mind
when I come back to that later I'm gonna
explain that so
we have the on button done the final
thing is the start button so just like
before we're going to do an add
eventlistener and it's going to be a
click event listener and we're going to
do a function an anonymous function in
here it's an arrow function and here
we're going to just do one thing if this
is the start button and it should only
do something if the game is on so if on
or there's been a win we are going to
play so let me go through this if on
this is just a shorthand way of saying
if on equals true or when equals true
then call the play function which we're
going to get to in a minute here it'll
play the game so well you pick the start
button and we're going to play the game
so that's what we're gonna do now is
define the play function so this is how
so this is one way to define a function
this is called an arrow function that
was introduced in es6 there's another
way to define a function a more common
way is like this I'm going to use the
function keyword function play and I'm
going to so this is the name of the
function
this is anything we're gonna pass in to
the function which is gonna be nothing
in this case and then the whole function
is going to take place within these
curly braces here so first of all I'm
gonna go up and actually add some
semicolons to these here and at the when
you first try to play the game the first
thing we want to do is reset variables
now if it's the first time you've played
the game the variables will already be
reset
but if you're playing again we just want
to make sure the variables have been
reset so let's say we're gonna set when
to equal false because you're starting
the game you have one yet order is going
to equal an empty empty array we're
going to fill that in a second here the
player order again is going to equal
empty array the flash is going to equal
zero that there's been zero flashes
interval ID equals zero you scroll a
little bit here turn equals one turn
counter dot inner HTML equals one so
that's this count is going to go to one
as soon as you press start because we're
on the first round of the game well so
we're gonna have good equals true that
means the player hasn't hit anything
incorrect yet and now we are going to
use a for loop to fill up this order so
we need to randomly fill up this order
of this array here so we have four
different quadrants so we're gonna fill
up the this array with a random series
of numbers to indicate the order that
these are going to light up in the game
so this is how we're gonna do the for
loop for var so when you have a for loop
you pass in three different things you
initialize a variable I equals zero
we're going to loop until I is or we are
going to loop while I is less than 20
and then at the end of the loop we're
going to increment I so it's going to go
through this loop 20 times because in
this game you have to get 20 you have to
do 20 rounds before you win the game so
this is how we're going to fill the
array order dot push math.floor
math.random times 4 and then plus 1 so
this whole line basically gets a random
numbers between 1 and 4 and fill this
fills this array so this is the array
we're going to push something onto the
array and what we're going to push onto
the array we have this a random number
this gets a random decimal but when we
multiply it by 4 and then add 1 here it
gets number between 1 and 5 but it could
still be a decimal so math that floor is
going to round it down so we can
actually see what happens here by just
doing another console that log so I'm
gonna do a console dot log and I'm just
going to log order so if we go into our
page here and I'm going to open up the
JavaScript console if you with the power
button and the start button you will see
that we have this array
this is array right in the console and
it's just 20 numbers 20 random numbers
between 1 and 4 so that's how we've made
this array that's going to show the
order that those lights are going to
flash in the game so let's go back over
here and we'll set the comp turn to
equal true it starts with the computer
flashing lights and then the player has
to match those lights
and then we start the first turn so this
I'm going to just type in and I'll
explain what it means the interval ID
equals set interval game turn 800 so let
me break this down set interval means
it's going to run a function after every
certain amount of milliseconds so set
interval it's gonna run the game turn
function every 800 milliseconds that's
gonna make it so the computer flashes a
light on here every 800 milliseconds and
it's gonna keep repeating until this
interval is cleared now the interval is
gonna clear after all the lights have
flashed but I haven't I haven't done
that yet but we need this interval ID
here that's what we set up here and we
have it down here the reason why we have
an interval idea so we can clear the
interval so I told you we're gonna come
back up to here if you turn the power
off clear interval that means it's going
to stop
címon from flashing the colors because
it's going to stop running the game turn
function every 800 milliseconds and the
game turn function is what flashes the
colors so this starts the game so now
that we've referenced the game turn
function let's define the game turn
function okay the game turn function so
I define the function the same way
function game turn and then we are going
to say what's going to happen when this
function is called so on is going to
equal false now this is just a tricky
thing where whenever on equals false the
player cannot click any of these buttons
so while the computer is flashing colors
we don't want the the player to be able
to click any of the buttons so that's
why on is set to false here so now let's
see if flash equals turn then we're
gonna do something so that means if the
number of times the lights have flashed
equals the turn that we're on that turn
shows right here then that means the
computers turn is over so if the
computers turn is over we are going to
clear the interval and a bit wool will
show what happens if the computers turn
is not over but if it's done flashing
all the lights like that we're going to
clear the interval this is what we
talked about earlier with the interval
ID comp
turn is going to equal false and then
we're going to clear the color if any
colors are lit up and on is going to
equal true now the on is equal to true
that means the player can now start
pressing buttons on there so down here
if if it is the computers turn then
we'll do these things if the turns not
over if it's with the first thing we're
gonna do when I clear the color because
we're gonna clear the color from the
last time the computer lit up something
oh and that reminds me I forgot to put
the parenthesis on the end whenever
we're gonna call a function you have to
put parentheses on the end of the name
there so clear the color and now I'm
going to set a timeout set timeout is
very similar to set interval so set
interval is going to keep repeating this
over and over set timeout is going to do
something once after a certain number of
milliseconds
so again I'm going to use one of these
arrow functions from es6 and it's going
to run this function after a certain
number of milliseconds so I'll put the
milliseconds at the end so I haven't
defined what the function is but you can
see here that every four it was gonna
wait 200 milliseconds and then do what's
what's in here so what's in here is it's
going to flash a number or a color so we
have to know what colors is gonna flash
is it gonna flash the green red yellow
or blue
so we're gonna have an if statement here
so if order flash goes equals one okay
let me explain this line here so our
order is an array and so flash is the
the number of times we've flashed a
color and flash starts at zero and so
zero is the first item in the array so
if the first item in the array is 1 and
remember this array is an array of
random numbers 1 2 3 4 so if the first
time is 1 we're gonna run the one
function which we have to define later
that's gonna flash the green right here
and I'm just gonna copy this line and
we're going to do it three more times
another thing is normally with an if
statement here you're going to put in
these parenthesis what the condition is
and then you're gonna have a curly
brackets and you're gonna run the things
in the curly brackets if the condition
is true but you can also skip the curly
brackets and just put the thing to run
if the condition is true right after the
parentheses so inside the parentheses is
the condition
and then right afterwards is the
function you're gonna run if this
condition is true so this is going to be
two three four and these are going to be
functions two three four so it's going
to run the function to pay on what the
number is and then the last thing that
has to happen is the flash has to be
incremented so it started at zero but
it's going to go up one every time the
computer flashes this happens after 200
milliseconds because of this set
interval up here a light is going to
flash every 800 milliseconds but since
we have this 200 milliseconds here that
means it's going to stop flashing for
200 milliseconds and it's gonna flash
again to the end of 800 milliseconds
well I can demonstrate it by just making
these functions here the 1 2 3 4
functions and we can actually run this
and see what happens so I'm gonna make
the function 1 and we're not going to
pass in things to any of these functions
that's why this is always empty here and
now we're gonna say if noise and so if
it's if it should make a noise then it
will make a noise remember we had these
sounds here and our HTML and now we're
going to use them in our JavaScript so
var audio equals document dot get
element by ID clip 1
so this get element by ID is pretty much
very similar to the query selector but
query query selector you can use any CSS
selector and get element by ID you just
put an ID in here but since we already
know it's an ID we don't have to put a
hash mark now I could have put query
selector and then put hash mark clip one
if I just wanted to show you a different
way you could do this now this ID clip
one is right here if we go back to our
HTML clip one here so we're now getting
this sound effect and on the next line
we are going to play it by doing audio
dot play now we could have put this at
the top but I just decided to do it this
way where it's right in here instead of
up here with the rest and actually I'm
going to make one more change like quick
instead of var this will be a let I
already told you that that we don't
really use var anymore it's gonna play
the sound I'm gonna set the noise to
equal true just in case it was set to
false now you'll understand more of this
noise thing later when I want to show
you when the noise is set to false and
then top top left that style dot
background color equals light green okay
let me break this down for you so top
left is this thing right here that we
got with the query selector style means
we're going to change the CSS style you
can change the SS using JavaScript and
we are going to you change the
background color element right now
background color is green but we're
gonna set it to light green if I go into
my style and I find top left at
the background is dark green and then I
set the background color to be light
green so we have this thing here for
what happens when you click the one now
it's going to be pretty similar for two
three and four
so I'm just gonna copy this and that's
going to be two three four so I'm gonna
change this to two and this is clip two
and the color is gonna be tomato now
just so you know I could be using hex
codes or some other way to indicate a
color but hTML has a set of keywords
that you can use to specify certain
colors so tomato is a keyword to signify
a specific color in job in an HTML that
you will see soon when I do the example
so this is gonna be three and set that
to three four set that for this color is
going to be yellow and then this color
is going to be a light sky-blue okay I
think we have enough code here to do an
example so let me save that I'll refresh
here and if I press Start okay it's not
working let's check the console clear
color is not defined oh yeah
so I I just spelled this wrong so let's
see clear color and then I'll refresh
now let's try see if I get any clear
okay it's still I spelled it wrong but
then the problem is that I actually
never ought to find that function so
let's do that right now I'm gonna go
down here clear color
oh I just put the word function so a
function clear color I'm going to use a
line very similar to this where it says
top left style that background color
equals light green so top left that
style that background color equals dark
green because that's the initial color
that we specified in the CSS and then
same with this on top we got oh now I'm
seeing another problem now that I'm
actually copying and pasting we have top
left here this is supposed to be okay we
got top left here this is supposed to be
top right this is supposed to be bottom
left and this is supposed to be bottom
right so now I can continue to copy and
paste and I'll be getting the right code
here so let's see this instead of tomato
is going to be dark red and then the
bottom left instead of yellow is gonna
be golden rod see these are all HTML
color names and then the bottom right
instead of light sky-blue is going to be
dark blue okay let's see if we're gonna
get any errors now I'll power this on
press Start and it seems to be working
so let me close that for now so we could
see it just went and but never really
went back hmm so let's see if we've done
something wrong I was expecting the
color to turn off at some point oh but
the problem was they put dark color here
instead of dark green so it never turned
back to dark green so let's try it again
I'll save this refresh and start this
okay so now it turned green but now I
can't click
though so I'm trying to click here to
show that I know that this just lit up
but that's not working because we
haven't programmed that yet so that's
the next thing we're gonna program so to
make it so a player can click these
colors we're going to have to have some
more event listeners so let me move this
code up a little bit and I'm going to
add some more event listeners so top
left dot Eve dot add event listener and
this is gonna be another click event
listener because we're just look
listening for the user to click the top
left and just like before event so now
we're going to check if it's on
we only want a user to be able to click
there if the program is on so if it is
on we'll do a few things the player
order dot push one remember player order
is an array of the sections that the
player has clicked or pressed so if the
player puts us here it we're gonna push
one onto the player order array then
we're going to check if the player was
correct this is gonna be a function to
check to see if the player was right now
whether or not the player was right
we're going to call the one function now
this is the same function that the
computer called that just lights up that
color and now if the player has not one
if the player is not one yet then we're
gonna set the timeout and we're going to
clear the color so after three hundred
milliseconds we're going to make sure
the color is cleared that the color that
the user clicked is going to
clear after 300 milliseconds let's
actually test this out but I'm going to
comment out this checking if if they've
won because we haven't made that
function yet so let me refresh here Oh
actually only works if I click up here
yep
that worked except the color didn't
clearly because I forgot to put
parentheses here so let me just try
again to make sure everything works okay
we got that one to work and now well let
me uncomment this I'm just going to do
some copying and pasting because we're
going to do this for every corner so we
got top left now I'm going to do a top
right and for top right we're going to
push on the number two we're going to
call the two function
but everything else will be the same so
now we have bottom left bottom push on a
three this is going to be three
everything else is the same now we have
bottom right push on a four four and
everything is the same and now we just
need our check function these are all
calling a check function and this will
be one of our more complicated functions
so let's get to it
function check and so we're going to
check if if it's correct so if player
order in these brackets I'll put player
order dot length minus one that just
means the last thing that the player
clicked
if the player order does not equal the
real order at player order dot link last
one the last thing that the player
clicked then good equals false so if
they're not the same
good equals false remember good is true
if the player is getting everything
correct and good as false if the player
has something incorrect we'll just put
that on through the next line so it's
easier to read and so now if player
order dot length equals equals 20 that
means they've gotten every single one
right and good that means they haven't
missed anything if good equals true now
it could have just put and good I didn't
have to put good equals true in fact I
will just do that if round the twentieth
round and good we haven't got anything
wrong then we'll call the win game
function if good equals false that means
the player got something wrong we're
gonna do something else so first I'm
gonna flash the color this is a function
that we still have to write then the
turn counter dot inner HTML is going to
equal no that just means right in here
it's gonna say no and then the next
thing that's going to happen is that
we're going to set a timeout
and then the turn counter is going to be
set back to the turn number so it was
the the turn counter was set to no but
after a certain amount of milliseconds
is going to go back to the turn number
and then also we're going to clear the
color so we are flashing the color here
and then we're gonna clear the color
here after a certain number of
milliseconds and I'll just put those
milliseconds which is going to be 800
milliseconds we're also going to do
something special if we're in strict
mode here so if strict it for in strict
mode and I call the play function and
remember play function is just like
repeating the whole game starting the
game over with else if we're not in
strict mode then we can repeat the round
so let me set some things up here to
repeat the round so if you get something
wrong then the round is repeated if
you're not in strict mode so comp turn
is going to equal true and the flash is
going to equal zero and the player order
is going to be an empty array good
equals true because we now we're back to
having nothing wrong because the round
is just started and an oops interval ID
equals set interval so we're setting
we're starting this just like we did
before in the play function is with a
set interval by calling game turn with
800 every 800 milliseconds and then the
final thing that's going to be in this
function is noise equals false so so
remember we're still in the good equals
false if statement so if the player got
something wrong we're not
to play a noise noise is going to equal
false the you only play the noise if the
player got the right click on the right
thing so now we can see up here while we
check to see if noise is true we have a
few conditions so far the condition if
the player wins the game the condition
if the player is wrong but now there's
the condition if the player got it
correct but has not won the game yet so
that's the condition I'm going to do now
so if turn equals player order length
and good and we haven't won yet then
turn plus plus we've now gotten to the
next turn and we're going to clear the
player order for the next term to begin
comp turn is going to equal true flash
is going to equal zero turn counter dot
innerhtml
equals turn now there's there's some
code that's repeated from here to here
so there could be some room for
refactoring here and interval ID equals
set interval game turn again this would
be a prime place for some refactoring
since we have some repeated code here
and that's it for this check function
but within the check function we
reference two functions that haven't
been created yet the win game function
and the flash color function so let's do
those now first a flash color function
it's going to be very similar to the
check color function so similar than
start by copying and pasting so the
flash color do flash color we're going
to just set these to the the other
colors so light green and then step dark
red is going to be tomato instead of
goldenrod we'll have yellow and this is
me a light sky-blue and then the other
function is the wind game function I'll
put that at the end so function when
game and so when the game if someone has
won the game first we're going to do the
flash color function that I just defined
here whoops and then we're gonna do a
turn counter dot innerhtml is going to
be set to when and on is going to equal
false so now a user can't click anything
because on is equal false and then when
is equal to true because the game has
been won and that actually should be the
full game so let's do some tests to see
if anything goes wrong so just saved I'm
going to refresh here let's let's see
we'll hit the power button start ok ok
let's see what happens when you press
the wrong thing he says no and that goes
back who it was supposed to play this
again but it didn't so let's see what
went wrong
ok I have a spelling error right here so
this says stick it should say strict I'm
sure some of the viewers probably saw
that I spelled that wrong ok so that was
supposed to be if strict so it's
that refresh let's see what happens here
okay good it replayed from where I lost
now if I should turn under strict mode
if I get something wrong it should
replay from the beginning it's to start
a new game if I get something wrong yep
it went down to one it just started a
new game now let's test what happens if
we win
now I'm not gonna sit here and go
through 20 rounds to see it what happens
when I win I'm going to just make some
change in the code here so instead of
length equal 20 I'm going to change this
to length equal 3 so we can check what
happens after 3 rounds for winning the
game yep and see all of them light up
and it says win right there and so we
should be able to start again by just
pressing the start button yeah and then
if we turn we can turn it off any time
so you click the power button the light
went out and then this went out so we
have just created an entire Simon game
everything works I talked about some
areas of refactoring that you may be
able to work on on your own you can make
the this design a little better some of
this code that was repeated we can try
to not have repeated code and I saw some
other places like right here if cop turn
this could really even be an else
statement and you may be able to figure
out a way to not even have the comp turn
variable but that's something you can
try to figure out on your own thanks for
watching again my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good